bonjour vous avez découvert le sujet
vous connaissez bien dossier qu'est ce
qui a conduit à ces interpellations près
de 40 ans après les faits reprochés le
fait qu' il y avait des prescriptions
qui allait arriver et aussi des
expirations de peine selon la loi
italienne
donc depuis déjà deux ans le
le gouvernement italien les
gouvernements italiens parce qu'on en a
eu trois dans les deux dernières années
avait représenté les demandes
d'extradition
il ne faut pas oublier que il ya une
accélération dans ces dossiers et quand
l'italie avait réussi à m'arrêter cesare
battisti en 2019 en janvier 2009 à
l'époque la ministre de la justice
nicole belloubet et celle des affaires
européen
nathalie l'oiseau avait dit qu'il n'y
avait pas d'obstacle de la part de la
france se donne dans la procédure
d'extradition
cependant il ne faut pas oublier qu'à
l'époque on parlait des quatorze 14
procédures d'extradition
là on est arrivé seulement à 10 donc il
ya eu quand même du temps qui a été
gâchée et ce n'est pas vraiment effectif
ce n'est pas complètement vrai dire
qu'il ya une une collaboration serré
entre paris et rome
non seulement à cause tout cas des monts
dire calcul si on veut dire français
mais aussi parce que quand il ya eu un
temps le changement de gouvernement
italien
en été 2019 quand donc matteo salvini
très clairement à quitter le
gouvernement
il ya eu moins d'intérêt de la part du
gouvernement italien comptait 2 de
continuer à conduire à essayer de tenir
à l'extradition de ces criminels une
demande de l'italie depuis des années à
laquelle la france n'avait pas n'avait
quasiment jamais accédé l'avocat de l'un
des anciens membres des brigades rouges
qualifie l'arrestation de son client de
trahison car la france leur a offert le
droit d'asile est une sorte de
protection qui leur est retiré
aujourd'hui quel est votre regard
là-dessus je pense que c'est là si la
france veut être crédible dans le dans
la lutte mais les contre le terrorisme
que malheureusement un sanglante notre
pays depuis au moins 2012 je parle de
terrorisme islamiste mais elle ne peut
pas faire comme si d'autres
auteurs des crimes et des tuileries
pouvait vivre tranquillement et sans
être arrêté ici en france parce que
sinon il y aurait deux poids deux
mesures et pira ça serait inacceptable
la position de la france qui se
considère comme l'une des souvenirs pays
principaux qui est engagée dans la
construction de l'union européenne
on parle souvent des collaboration entre
les justices des différents pays de
l'union européenne il ya là c'est un cas
concret qui nécessite une collaboration
très forte et direct ils essaient de
sortie du ministre de la justice je n'ai
strictement aucun état d'âme c'est ce
qu'a dit eric dupond-moretti qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire
ben il faut pas oublier que eric dupond
moretti est aussi italien donc peut-être
il a une connaissance un peu plus
précise de ce qu'ils on va présenter les
années des plans pour les italiens mais
juste pour le rappeler
c'est quelque chose qui d'ailleurs il a
dit lui même il hier pendant la
conférence de presse les années de plomb
ont fait quelque 4000 blessés et plus de
350 morts entre la fin des années 60 et
le début des années 80 donc on il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup d'innocents qui ont
été tués par des formations d'extrême
gauche et d'extreme droite qui
voilà lutter entre guillemets pour une
idéologie et puis je comprends aussi les
paroles du ministre de la justice parce
que il ne faut pas oublier que ceux qui
défend non je peux je veux dire les
personnalités intellectuelles par
exemple qui défend les anciens
terroristes italiens disent que
désormais ces personnes se sont greffés
qu'une vie d'artistes franco italien
vous réagissiez après l'arrestation de
ses sept membres notamment des brigades
rouges interpellation hier en france
alors que deux autres membres se sont
rendus ce matin